all right so i just got done uh making a
video about this paper and i was trying
to upload it so i looked at the open
review page and i i read the first
review and i just thought i had to show
you this now before you see the review
of the paper but just look at this
review so the paper is about optimizer
grafting
it's about transferring the learning
rate of one optimizer to another
optimizer it has some experiments in it
and proposes this algorithm to
investigate sort of learning rate
schedules
okay main review
s1 which i guess is strength one a large
amount of experiments is conducted
plenty of results shown in the appendix
okay s2 a novel optimizing mode of
grafting two different optimizers is
proposed got so you know a little bit
about what's in the paper
weakness one the paper structure is
strange
i recommend to read some published
proceedings to try to make this paper
more clearly
what
just to say these these are accomplished
researchers right uh that are the
authors of this paper actually show who
the authors are it's
the structure is straight i recommend
reading you know read a bit maybe maybe
a book maybe you know
you learn something
weakness too some form it may not be
legal okay
weakness three the theory is not
reasonable
not re
by the way the paper proposes no theory
um the theory is not reasonable in other
words you just tell me
you do it like this but not why it's
reasonable okay i mean that is a
that is a even though the paper explains
clearly why they do everything that
might be uh a criticism like you haven't
really given a theoretical foundation
for your reasons but then
actually i don't think adam grafted onto
std so this is the new method they
propose it's sgd with the learning rate
of adam actually i don't think adam
grafted onto sgd will be better than
adam
notice this is what they show in the
paper that they make experiments to show
that this is the case
and
it's not like this person has tried it
out and has said it doesn't work for me
or it doesn't work in this other paper
no no no the entire thing that this
person says is
i don't think this will happen
no reason what
why
what is this this is this is a type of
reviewers that people have to fight with
and then there's like some herberty
herberty herberty herbert i'm sorry if
they show in the paper that this is the
case then either you claim they are
lying
and or you have conflicting evidence or
anything like this but simply sitting
here saying
i don't think so
what what
i mean ah um
then we
why th this is this this is why
i'm confused in my view this is method
is more like an sgd with multiplying a
large constant to its gradient i mean at
the end that's what it is but
like has this person actually read the
paper
weakness for i have a question that's a
weakness a weakness is i have a question
how to compute the norms
how to compute these norms
it's norms like the paper clearly like
they okay they don't say it's l2 norms
but they clearly you know how do you
compute the norm of a vector
is this calculated with this is answered
in the paper this is clearly answered
throughout the paper
if not figure one is a wrong example
well it's it is so
it's well how is it a weakness if you
have a question that is answered in the
paper
and then weakness five the results shown
in tables are not strong enough
right a large amount of experiment is
conducted and plenty of result is shown
in the appendix
the result shown is not strong enough
well what what do you mean not strong
enough like
not highly performant enough because
that's not what the paper is about not
strong enough you mean not enough
because
well the other reviews it's not like the
other reviews are necessarily good
reviews of the paper but at least they
have some criticism like hey you you
know you're not theoretically motivated
or something like this and and they're a
bit extensive but like this is what this
is
you know
it's it's it's i guess you know if
you're some company researcher and so on
you know your bonus might depend on a
submission being accepted or not which
you know if you're at google or so i
mean
you're doing well right but um if you're
like a phd student and you need to get
papers accepted in within a certain
amount of years and then
i don't think that what you clearly show
in the paper is the way it is because i
just pull it like somewhere out here
okay
enough of me ranting let's go into the
paper by the way i make one mistake i
make one mistake in the paper which is
kind of similar to what the person is
here so i
there is a diagram and i'm gonna just
gonna describe it right here where i
where i say there's an arrow like this
and an arrow like this and i say well
the combined update step would be
something like in the in between which
is is not the case uh it would be
actually one of the arrows just rescaled
z
erata okay
bye last thing this is the best i forgot
confidence you are absolutely certain
about your assessment this is the
highest score this is the reviewer
rating themselves you are very familiar
with the related work and checked the
math under other details really because
here it says i'm confused and
i have a question
the following is a community-inspired
paper review which means that we have
talked about this paper in our discord
paper discussions we do this regularly
and i can take a lot of good opinions
from there and bring them into my videos
if you're interested in joining these
paper discussions uh join our discord
and watch the events channel
hi there today we're going to look at a
paper by namon agarwal rohan anil ellad
hassan tomer koren and serial chung but
it is not the paper that you see right
here see this paper is called
disentangling adaptive gradient methods
from learning rates and it's on archive
with the authors now allow me to present
this paper right here under review at
iclear with anonymous authors that's
called learning rate grafting
transferability of optimizer tuning now
suspiciously the two papers have pretty
much exactly the same content so you
know safe to assume that we might make
an educated guess about who these
authors might be i'm going to review the
obviously newer version because newer is
always better
so what is this paper about this paper
is about a technique called learning
rate grafting and grafting means that we
transfer the learning rate from one
optimizer to another optimizer
they have a bit of a graphic right here
so what we would do is we would take two
different optimizers and think of things
like sgd
or
adam or something like this so
these are fairly popular optimizers in
deep learning we would take one of them
and that one would give us the
information of what the direction of
updates of our weight is so let's j
let's actually say sgd here is this
purple one in this direction you can see
that will follow in general the
direction that sgd tells us to go
however
we don't go
exactly what sgd we don't do what sgd
tells us to do instead of we take the
learning step size or the learning rate
from adam and we go
that far so one algorithm dictates where
we go the other algorithm dictates how
far we go
and what this does is it implicitly
transfers
transfers the learning rate schedule
from one optimizer to another optimizer
and as a result of this
many many things happen so
one
simple thing that results from this is
we're able to investigate some of the
differences between the optimizers
surprisingly one of the things that this
paper finds is that
maybe the different optimizers
it's a bit over
let's say over described over hyped what
the differences really are between them
it a lot of times it simply comes down
to the learning rate schedule that the
optimizers induce and as soon as you
transfer that to another optimizer the
other optimizer will perform just as
well so the differences between a lot of
these optimizers might just come down to
the learning rate schedule
another thing that they can do is they
can for example transfer these learning
rate adapt adaption sorry adaptations
that one does to the other
and
that
makes it in practice um that gives you
benefits in practice for example adam
let's look at adam adam maintains
uh
three buffers for every single parameter
so for
let's or let's go sgd sgd for every
parameter w
it has
one
um
it essentially just updates that
parameter if you have sgd with momentum
then you also have the momentum
parameter that it maintains so for every
parameter there is a momentum parameter
and then as a gradient comes in it
updates the momentum parameter and that
it uses that to update the weights so
one buffer essentially per parameter
that we want to treat
atom on the other hand maintains like
three buffers i don't exactly remember
what they all are but
they are like the
squared sums of gradients and then they
are somehow the current gradient squared
uh or some exponential moving average
across that in any case it maintains
like three different buffers per
parameter
and that also means that it has like
double at least double or three times
the memory requirements of sgd right sgd
even with momentum
needs a lot less memory than atom and
that's a big deal because memory is one
of the things that especially on gpus is
a limited commodity so if you're able to
reduce the amount of memory that your
optimizers need then that means that you
can train bigger models because now you
have a bunch of free space
so what this grafting method allows you
to do is it allows you to essentially
run sgd
adjust it for the learning rate schedule
of adam but without having to run adam
you can simply transfer the learning
rate schedule or the adjustments to the
learning rate from adam to sgd and you
know that's a that's a pretty cool thing
so we're gonna look
gonna go look into how this paper does
it what it suggests and it's pretty
straightforward paper i think it's
pretty pretty short pretty cool to read
and yeah so what is
what exactly is grafting they first do a
little bit of an excursion into
preliminaries um and that essentially
presents these adaptive optimizers these
adaptive methods so if you look at sgd
what it does is it pure plain sgd
its update rule which they characterize
as an algorithm a right here that takes
in the current weights of the neural
network or whatever system you optimize
and the current gradient right so w are
the weights g is the gradient both at
time step t
it will output for the next weight so a
always gives you
w
t plus one
it will output the current weight
minus a step size times the gradient
this is classic gradient descent
now this right here is a learning rate
schedule so even in gradient descent
people do learning rate schedules uh
sometimes there is a bit of a warm-up
and then you might reduce it over time
maybe after some epochs i go down and so
on or you might not right
but these are usually handcrafted
learning rate schedules
now when you go to other things such as
adam or adegrad or anything like this
for of all of these other grad is
probably the most simple
so the reasoning behind adegrad is the
following if
if you have a lost landscape which we're
going to draw here as some sort of a
topological plot so every line is an is
sort of a
same loss height and this is the global
optimum right here so you start out
somewhere here you calculate the
gradient the gradient maybe goes in this
direction so that's the local the local
tangent to
these these iso lines
that's pretty simple right you see you
go straight uh here even if you have
some sort of a bit of a mistake at the
beginning because it's stochastic you
can see in general you go downhill
however
what if
uh the landscape doesn't look like this
but it actually looks you know like
really
skewed in one of the dimensions
so it's really steep in one of the
dimensions that it's really flat in the
other dimension now what happens here is
that if you start off the same thing
maybe you have a little bit of noise
you tend to make
if you do this step so if you look at
this what you're going to do is probably
you're going to make a big step into
this and then it's really steep right
now it's really steep into this
direction so you're going to bounce over
here like really far and then it's
really steep in that direction so you're
going to bounce over here really far so
because it's so steep in that direction
you're going to bounce around
way too
weight with way too big of a step size
just because one direction this
direction is way steeper than this
direction
so what do methods like adegrad do at a
grad flattens out this landscape by
observing i mean the algorithm doesn't
see the landscape it only sees these
points where you're at and the
corresponding gradients so what adegrad
does is it simply says i'm going to look
at one of these gradient steps right
let's say i'm here
this is my gradient here i'm going to
look at
what's the change in this direction
what's the change in this direction and
then i'm going to normalize by it so the
update rule for adegrad is something
like wt plus 1 equals wt minus some step
size times
the gradient but now the gradient gets
scaled by the sum of square gradients
and the square root of that so what this
means is that i'll take all of the
gradients that i've seen so far
i square them and then i sum them all up
and
in essence
this is element wise by the way so these
are vectors
and we are talking about diagonal
autograd so in essence what this says is
that if i have my gradient vector here
i'll put a matrix in front of it and
every entry
in this matrix is
1 divided by the square of the gradients
i've seen so far so it's a bit of a
normalization if my gradients in this
particular direction were really large
i'll divide by a lot if my gradients
were really small i'll divide by just a
little bit so you can see that it
transforms a landscape like this to
implicitly look
much much more well conditioned and you
can even see because we have a total sum
right here
that goes on with time that there is a
little bit of even a decreasing learning
rate built in because the square is
always positive so we're simply going to
add on to these buffers and that means
that we are going to decrease our
learning rate implicitly over time
so
here you can see you can see two things
you can see that um
you know these these pre-conditioners
they have their reasons for existing
first of all but much more important
they introduce an implicit learning rate
schedule right this thing right here
is an implicit learning rate schedule
and all of these algorithms like adegrad
adam and so on they introduce exactly
that so this part right here that's the
implicit learning rate schedule and
we're now we're now wondering um
so how much of the success of these
optimizers comes from the fact that they
do
something like this right here where
they you know look at each of the
coordinates and they you know they uh
they adapt with respect to how steep
they are and so on and how much all how
much simply comes from the fact that
they say well now you need to go far now
you need to go not so far now you need
to make a big step now you need to make
a small step
so that's what we're wondering
and grafting allows us to answer these
questions so in grafting what we do is
we
leave the optimizers as they are so here
we would leave sgd to do sgd right
um
so
again we're at the start here i'm
running out of colors to draw over top
of one another let's go with green
we're at the start right here
and we wanna and let's say we've made
this step now we want to go into this
direction right sgd would make a big
jump right here
um
and add a adegrad or adam maybe would do
two things it would say
well uh since this one direction is very
steep i'm not going to make that big of
a step into that direction i maybe make
a smaller step and i also adjust my
direction and what crafting does is it
says
okay we're going to take your suggestion
of how far we should go
but we're still going to go into the
same direction that we originally went
so we're taking the step size that
the
one optimizer suggests and where we'll
transfer it onto the direction of
another optimizer so this allows us to
answer the question what's really
important here the step size schedule or
the direction the particular direction
that these optimizers produce
and the answer is going to be the step
size so the grafting algorithm is
detailed here this is the simple version
which is i believe called global
grafting
so you can see we're we're gonna note
we're gonna take this right here this
notation so m
uh is stands for magnitude algorithm i
guess i don't i don't know i've invented
it d stands for direction algorithm and
um m d is the combined grafted algorithm
so what we're going to do is we're going
to feed the same input
uh the current weight and the current
gradient to both of the algorithms
they will manage their state's internal
states independently but yet they will
not yet
update the weights they will simply
suggest each an update
what we'll then do is we'll look at two
quantities
this right here and this right here so
this is the step
that
this here is wt plus one
according to algorithm m and this is wt
plus one
according to algorithm d and we're going
to look at both of the steps that they
would suggest right if we subtract this
here this is what step do you suggest
and then what we do is we compute the
norms of these steps
and
we'll simply normalize the quantity
of d right here by the ratio of these
norms
if we rewrite this a little bit you can
see much more clearly what's going on
this is wt
plus
and then
i'll write the norm the first norm here
uh w m minus w
t
and then i'll write the second thing wd
minus wt
divided by the norm of wd minus wt
oops norm
so there you can see that we'll take the
direction
ah
we'll take the direction of the d
optimizer
and we take the direction because by
dividing by its norm we normalize it
so this always has length one right
so this is simply the direction of the
step that the d optimizer would do
and we multiply it by the norm of the
step that the m optimizer would do
notice m only comes in here through this
norm so m has no influence on the
direction that we go while d has no
influence on the magnitude of the step
because we always divide by its own
magnitude
so that's the grafting algorithm
and they have some properties right here
it's you can graft an algorithm onto
itself it won't do anything
you can grab multiple algorithms and so
on it's not commutative yada yada it's
not necessarily a descent method which
is interesting but
i guess irrelevant because that i
consider that an edge case
and now they have one more
trick up their sleeve how they make it
um more interesting namely this is what
they call global grafting where it's
just one global learning rate right this
whole norms these whole norms here they
are
they are just one number at the end okay
they can also do this for example for
each layer individually so they divide
up the parameters into layers and then
do it for each layer individually
if they were to do it for each parameter
individually right then it would be
it would not
have any effect
so if they do it for each parameter
individually i think it would just
revert to being the old uh sorry
it would just revert to being
the m algorithm right this that's what
they say right here if they do it for
each parameter individually they might
as well just run m because the magnitude
of each parameter um is dictated
by fully by m
and we don't so we
well
we don't calculate the direction of d
because each of the entries is
separately divided by itself so d will
just output a bunch of ones
so yeah that's
that's the reason and because the norms
are just of size one in any case that's
a bit of
that's a bit of pushing it to the limit
we can either do this globally or we can
do it for each layer individually that's
this partition parameter right here
so what does this
where does this go
what they try is notice that we're still
in the case where we need to run both
algorithms simultaneously right so for
each step we're here for each step we
have to consult std what would you do
and then adam what would you do and then
we do the grafting between the two
things and then we maybe get this
direction right here we go on we again
ask both optimizers we go on in the
experiments they do a good job of
controlling for the actual compute that
they give
to these experiments and and therefore
you can make some assumptions but
one worrying thing about me just as a
side note is that atom has this for
example this internal state right so it
has this it accumulates the gradient
into buffers and so on
yet
we make an update step that is not into
the direction that these buffers would
suggest so technically these buffers are
wrong for the path that we're taking the
buffers expected that we're going to
take this path right here and um i'm not
sure how much
how much you know we um
how much we actually
miss due to that
i also don't know how we easily would
correct it but i would just
wanted to say that the internal state
is updated
as if we were to actually take the step
that the algorithm suggests however
we're not going to take that step at the
end so this is a bit of a shady practice
in this grafting algorithm
in any case as we do run both
at the same time you can see right here
so there's an experiment where
experiments for implicit hyperparameter
transfer comparing hyperparameter search
for sgd with momentum versus grafting
with
and then
m is sgd
sorry
so it's adam
grafted onto sgd is that
is that true
m
because it seems like d is sgd right
it's always m d
and then sgd is at the end
well
maybe that's wrong i don't know
as the way i understand it is that you
have the trials
uh with sgd you have trial with adam
which is in blue right here and then if
you take this grafting approach
and you do atom along with sgd so you do
the direction of sgd but the step size
that adam would do you see that you
almost get the same performance right
in fact in this particular case sgd
with the atom step size even outperforms
adam like a tiny little bit
if you go to a higher batch size that's
no longer the case but also here you see
that
it seems to be that as soon as you get
this step size right
um
not only can you not match it with any
humanly chosen let's say step size of
sgd which would be all the the gray
stuff
but also
immediately most of the or all of the
benefits of the atom optimizer versus
sgd vanish so it really seems to be a
thing of the step size and as far as i
understand it that's the global grafting
yeah they they do make some like they
mention a bunch of times that this
number right here um no it's layer wise
sorry it's layer wise grafting you
mentioned a bunch of times that this is
higher than just using atom
but
i'm not sure how exactly robust this is
especially as you see here if you go to
the higher batch sizes it is a different
different story
they also do some experiments with um
with resnets
which
aren't as
cool like
they're not as performant so here you
see a lot of the times that they take
sgd
which is a good algorithm for these
types of problems
by the way sgd was a bad algorithm for
bert that's why they used it as the
direction
and grafted the learning rate onto it in
these particular cases sgd is actually
pretty good and so is adam as you can
see right here
and
the other algorithms at a grad seems to
be kinda bad if they now graphed sgd or
adam on to adegrad which you can see
here with the layer wise or the global
grafting
it helps a little bit right compared to
just add a grad but it's not like it's
not like that it really gets into a
highly performant region
so
i guess the conclusions of this is that
sometimes or is that
the the step size schedule
is an important parameter
it does it is part of why some of the
optimization algorithms um
outperform others it might not be
all of the reason
i guess that's
that's a a cautious a cautious thing you
can say right here they go into a little
bit of analysis for example um about
this
giving you sort of new
a bit of new uh insights
so for example people have come up with
this yellow learning rate schedule for
sgd there's a bit of a
warm-up and then there is just a decay
after
every few epochs and so on and if you
transfer that to add a grad so if you
graphed that on undergrad right the
trick is we don't transfer it we don't
simply say well these are the steps we
always we ask both optimizers and then
the resulting learning rate schedule
might be a different one from either of
the two
and the cool thing is that here the
algorithm seems to really decide kind of
on a on this polynomial
warm up for adegrad before then
using this decay that comes from sgd
so it's pretty neat that it allows you
to kind of gain an insight into what
these algorithms are doing
they do a last thing right here where
they say can we get away
with not running both algorithms at the
same time
and that's what they they do right here
um
so what is this
they
take adegrad and they no they take adam
sorry
they take adam and they take sgd
and they run it for just 2000 steps this
is very small number of steps let's say
in
training of bird so this is just the
first few iterations they run both
and what they do is they observe the
norm ratio
during
grafting so they do this grafting where
they run both and they observe the
ratio of norms between what one and what
the other one would suggest
okay so essentially they do this
grafting
and they observe the
how these step sizes between the two
relate
and then they say
okay we'll just take the median over
these 2 000 steps
and that is going to be
our learning rate correction to sgd
so essentially we're saying
we're going for 2 000 steps how does the
learning rate of the
the implicit step size of adam compare
to sgd over these steps
maybe it's always 10 times higher for
some layers maybe it's 50 times higher
for other layers you can see they split
this up into different
different layer types like embeddings or
self-attention and so on
and then they say well okay so from here
on out let's just run sgd only std
but always correct the step size
by this ratio
and
that actually works apparently so
i don't think there's a plot necessarily
right here
but you can see this is one of the
results so with atom you again get this
69.5 sgd is way worse because this is
burt
but then
the combination as far as i understand
it that is this
this discovered per layer learning rate
correction so that's one number per
layer
even then sgd is
better if you have this learning rate
correction given by adam than just atom
itself a little bit but still it is
or is it not no this is grafted sorry
i think this is the one
this here is the one where they keep it
constant and that is not better but it
is at least it is the same right like
i hope the rounding the rounding was in
their favor right here otherwise they
they'd have like added added like one
one digit and had to it could claim that
they're better
but in any case it's pretty cool to see
that the performance here jumps by quite
a bit and uh
it's not that much worse as if you had
executed adam alongside right that's the
70.1
uh on the bottom here they have
different
different kind of even more
quantizations which
make the result worse most often but it
seems like if you get them exactly
correct then it can improve by a little
bit not too big of a fan of these kinds
of things it shows that you can go
simpler
but um
yeah you have to kind of hit it exactly
right with this hyperparameter and that
defeats the purpose a little bit
in any case i think this is a
the two powerful things from this paper
first of all this can be used for
investigating these optimizers right
because you can now see aha here is you
know here is the exact effect that the
step size schedule
is having on one or the other optimizer
you can sort of mix the step size from
one with the directional
update rule of another one
the second one is that something like
this where you simply quickly observe
how two optimizers stack up against each
other match each other in the step sizes
they would suggest
maybe you need a little bit more memory
at the beginning because you up you
execute both of them
however you only need to do this for a
few number of steps before you can then
go ahead and simply take what you
learned and save a whole bunch of memory
because
as they do right here now they only from
here on out they only execute
sgd
no more adam the ratios are fixed and
they're per layer
so that's that's pretty cool and pretty
powerful especially i'm wondering how
these things generalize so can i take
sort of these can i take the
ratios of one network and
transfer them to another one with a
slightly different architecture maybe a
bigger network or a different problem a
different data set so this seems to be a
pretty exciting future direction
because it makes everything a lot more
efficient if we simply know that aha
embedding layer okay you know let's just
multiply that by 50 or something like
this
and then lastly this is a bit of my
worry is that
i don't know where we go if we if what i
said right here the internal state of
the optimizer assumes we're taking a
certain step yet we take a different
step i don't know how that influences
the entire grafting algorithm
they have a lengthy appendix if you want
to go into that of
a lot of
a lot of different results right here
and
but i don't want to go into that right
here
in the conclusion they say we've
introduced grafting binary operation
which blends the behavior of two
optimization algorithms towards
investigating the entanglements between
widely used adaptive preconditioning
rules and learning rate schedules
yadda yadda
furthermore we have shown that grafting
can be used to extract standalone
learning rate corrections enabling us to
train a transformer using sgd with
momentum for the first time
well i guess people have been able to
train them before just not to
satisfactory uh to satisfactory
accuracies
we hope that this funding will simulate
further empirical research power of
simple per layer learning rate schedules
okey-dokey
the empirical phenomena examined in this
work seemed to be unexplained by current
theory that is also an interesting point
we hope that the experiments enabled by
grafting will aid in developing more
robust beliefs about both adaptive
methods and learning rate schedules and
guide future theoretical inquiry
all right theory people here's something
for you to explain
all right i
hope you have enjoyed this overview of
learning rate grafting sorry for
de-anonymizing the paper right away but
uh
yeah
that's a bit silly anyway in any case if
you like this
hit subscribe smash like
get enough sleep
and i'll see you next time bye